Only a very small percentage of academic
writers ever get their work published
and even fewer of them receive
citations. And the biggest mistake that
holds them back is that they blindly
followed the rulebooks of academic
writing. But the real tragedy is not
that they don't get citations. It's that
their research doesn't impact all the
lives that it was destined to. Imagine
if Watson and Crick's discovery of the
structure of DNA had never been
published. there would be less
understanding of genetic disease, no
crisper and no personalized medicine.
Fortunately, Watson and Crick were
really good writers and their use of
academic writing style is one of the
reasons why their discovery had such a
great impact on the scientific
community. So today, we're going to
follow in their footsteps by looking at
three tips for academic writing style
that have been scientifically proven to
increase the likelihood that your
research will get published in high
impact journals and cited by others in
your field. Welcome back to Writer
Science, the channel where we explore
the art and science of academic and
professional writing. If you're new
here, my name is William and I'm an
English professor based in South Korea.
And the writing tips in this video come
from an analysis of over 30,000 articles
with high impact ratings. That is those
which are published in the top journals
or which receive a ton of citations. And
the results might surprise you. They
certainly surprised me. Now, of course,
scientific ideas spread because they're
valuable. But let me ask you this. If a
tree falls in the forest and nobody
hears it, does it make a sound?
[screaming]
And if you make a discovery and nobody
reads about it, does it make an impact?
The main reason why so many academic
writers don't get the attention they
deserve is not because their work isn't
valuable. It's because of the biggest
mistake going. They just blindly follow
the academic writing style rule books
and never learn how to use academic
writing style effectively. And for that
reason, their ideas are dead in the
water. Luckily, the first common mistake
to avoid is pretty straightforward. In
the propagation of ideas, it's essential
to prioritize the cognitive
accessibility of the discourse over the
display of the originator's error
addition. Got it? Good. Moving on. The
second mistake is according to the rule
books, academic writing is supposed to
be complex. If it's too simple, they
say, then it will make your ideas seem
too simple and they'll never get
published in any high impact journal.
And it's actually true that the
complexity of your writing style has a
big effect on whether or not your ideas
will be accepted for publication, except
that it's in exactly the opposite
direction. This study by Oenheimer took
a group of original essays and then kept
the ideas the same, but increased the
complexity of the language. If the rule
books are right, then you would expect
that the more complex articles would
have higher acceptance rates than the
simpler originals. But exactly the
opposite is true. The essays with the
highest complexity were rated worse than
the moderately complex ones, which in
turn were rated worse than the simple
originals. And this is true across
genres from academic reports to college
admissions essays. Simpler writing leads
to higher acceptance rates. And to show
you why that is, I need you to consider
the way that ideas spread. If an idea is
carried by complex language, then it
will never make it off the page and into
the mind of the reader. That's because
there's only so much work that a reader
is willing to do to unpack your writing
and find your message. On the other
hand, when an idea is presented in clear
language, it can move more easily from
the page to the mind of the reader. And
when the reader can grasp our idea
easily, they'll be more likely to carry
it [music] and pass it on to others in
the form of a citation. Many academics
like to dress up their ideas in complex
language in order to make themselves
appear smart. But this just turns off
the reader. So the goal of our writing
should not be to make ourselves seem
smart. Instead, we should write in a way
that makes the reader feel smart. Now,
one thing I have to make clear here is
that we're not talking about dumbing
down our ideas. We don't want to talk to
the reader like they're a fifth grader.
What we're talking about is packaging
our ideas in a way that's easier for the
reader to process. But how do we reduce
complexity? This is our idea and this is
the DNA of our idea. Except we don't
call it DNA, we call it syntax. Syntax
is like the idea of DNA because it's the
code that we use to share and replicate
our ideas. If the code is complex, then
there are going to be mutations in the
DNA and the idea won't make it off the
page and into the mind of the reader.
So, we need to make sure that the code
is as simple and straightforward as
possible. Here's the same idea presented
in two different codes. Which one is
easier to understand? It's the second
one of course because in the DNA of our
ideas there are only two elements. There
are content words like nouns, verbs and
adjectives and function words like
prepositions and determiners. Each of
these codes uses the same content words
but one uses way more function words
than the other. And when a sentence has
a lot of these function words, it
becomes really heavy with all these
branches. Academic articles written with
fewer determiners and fewer prepositions
in the introductions get more citations.
The fewer the function words, the
simpler the DNA. And the simpler the
DNA, the easier it is for the reader to
get our idea and the more likely they
will be to share that idea with others.
Which brings us to the second rule about
academic writing style. According to the
rule book, academic writing should be
formal and impersonal. After all, we're
not talking about literature here. This
is science and science is objective. And
this objectivity, according to the
rulebook, should be reflected in the
writing style itself.
It doesn't matter who does the research.
What matters is the research. That's why
so many academic writers choose to use
passive sentences and avoid the use of
personal pronouns. And it's also why
their research doesn't get published or
cited. To understand why impersonal
language doesn't work in academic
writing, take a look at this. It's a
Klein bottle and it represents a
mathematical surface that has no edges
or orientation, no outside and no
inside. It can be thought of as a higher
dimensional analog to the Mobius strip.
But unlike the Mobius strip, which has
only one side and one boundary, the
Klein bottle has no boundaries at all.
All right. So, now compare that
description of the Klein bottle with
this one from a popular TED talk. I'm
one of the very few people uh if not the
only person in the world that makes
Klein bottles. Okay. Right. Right away.
I hope all of your eyes glaze over. This
is a Klein bottle. For those who know,
those of you in the audience who know,
you roll your eyes and say, "Yep, I know
all about it. It's one-sided. It's a
bottle whose inside is its outside. It
has zero volume and it's uh it's
non-orientable and has wonderful
properties. If you take two moious loops
and sew their common edge together, you
get one of these. And I make them out of
glass. And and and I'd love to talk to
you about this. Which presentation are
you more likely to remember? People
relate to other people. And readers are
people. So whenever there's a person
present in the story, it's a lot easier
for the reader to connect with the story
and receive the ideas. And that
connection makes it a lot easier for the
writer to persuade the reader that the
research is valuable. Now, it's
important to note that this doesn't work
in every place throughout the entire
article. Personal language only helps
with citations when they're in the front
matter. By contrast, academic articles
that use personal language in the middle
section, that is the methods and the
results, actually receive fewer
citations. And to understand why that
is, we need to consider the purpose of
these sections. The purpose of the
midsection is to unpack the finer
details of the experiment itself. It's
sometimes known as the empirical
section. At this point of the report,
the reader doesn't care about the story.
What they're interested in is the
author's methods and results. So, it
makes sense that the most successful
authors would use impersonal language
and passive sentences in the middle
section because that lets the writer
hide the author and put the focus on the
research itself. On the other hand, the
purpose of the front matter, that is the
abstract and the introduction is to
motivate our reader to get them
interested in our research. If we
introduce this research using impersonal
language, then it's like the client
bottle. The reader's not going to care.
But like the mad scientists in the TED
talk, the most successful articles use
personal language in the abstract and
introduction in order to capture the
reader's interest and motivate them to
read the rest of the report. But not
only will using personal language help
capture the reader's interest, it'll
also change the way the reader perceives
you. When you introduce valuable
research using personal language, then
the reader will associate that value
with you and it'll make you seem more
authoritative. So, if your work is any
good, then don't be shy. Let the reader
know that it's yours, especially in the
front matter. If you follow the lousy
rule books and stick with impersonal
language, then your research will appear
lifeless and detached as though the
ideas, your ideas are just out there
floating in the ether. Now, to
understand the third and final tip about
academic writing style, I want you to
take a look at these two restaurant
reviews. Which one seems more
convincing? The restaurant serves
delicious steamed hams.
Steamed hams.
The restaurant served delicious steamed
hams.
Steamed hams. Many people would agree
that the one written in the present
tense sounds more convincing. But if the
present tense is more convincing, then
why do so many academic rule books tell
us to write about research using the
past tense? A lot of people think that
they have to use the past tense to talk
about research in the past. Makes sense,
right? It's the past tense. Research
happened in the past. But that's wrong.
It's kind of a deeper grammatical point
here that we don't have to get into, but
the basic message is that tense has
nothing to do with time. And there's no
rule that says you have to use the past
tense to talk about research just
because it happened in the past. In
fact, there are some really good reasons
to use the present tense whenever you
talk about your own research. When we
divorce tense from time, it becomes
really easy to see why authors who write
about their research using the present
tense receive more citations. Just like
the restaurant reviews, the present
tense makes your research seem more
current, more relevant, and more
applicable. The past tense sounds like
old news. It's p stale, and forgotten.
So, when writing about your own
research, using the present tense will
make it seem more current, more alive,
which makes it more likely to get picked
up for citation. Yes, the research
happened in the past, but if we follow
the rulebooks and write about our
research using the so-called past tense,
then it's going to seem like old news.
So, breathe some life into your research
by using the present tense. So, I really
hope you see that if your research isn't
getting the attention that it deserves,
it's really not your fault. It's the
fault of the old academic rule books.
But to tell you the truth, if it's
citations that you're looking for, you
would actually be better off not writing
a research report at all. And instead,
you need to check out this video right
here because it's going to show you how
to write a different kind of academic
report that has been shown to get cited
way more often and over longer periods
of time than the standard IMRAD research
report. So, be sure to go check it out.